oh hi everyone
what's up it's me uh we're playing tell
me why
um this is the latest game from don't
nod
who made life is strange it's supposed
to be very life is strange
just full disclosure not generally my
type of game i like things that are more
combat orientated
um generally uh but i thought i'd jump
into it anyway
you know i like playing new game
releases and checking them out so
let's do that obviously right off the
bat of the stream
uh let me know if my audio mix is off
um yeah i'm playing on xbox the game is
on xbox and pc i believe chapter one is
out today i do have all three chapters
but only allowed to stream the first one
right now so
okay press any button will do
thought you'd never ask
well that's taking a while okay
looks about right new game let's go
yeah um for anyone who's not familiar
with these games i mean donut did
actually also make remember me which was
more combat orientated i liked that game
and i kind of wish they'd make a
remember me too of like something else
like
in that style i liked a lot of the ideas
i didn't love the execution of the whole
thing but you could like build combos
and
button button map them however you
wanted it was neat
yeah they basically make like they like
interactive films
sort of what don't not is known for
doing um always set in america
often a female protagonist which i find
extra entertaining because it's like a
bunch of french dudes
ooh i am in front of text there you go
alaska my favorite u.s state
what are you all right what are you all
right how are we doing how are we doing
should be okay should be okay
hey kiddo hey i need to ask you a few
questions
okay yeah let's go i did i just realized
all the people in the chat
singing backstreet boys lyrics
can you tell me what happened tonight
i i went to show her my haircut
she had a gun oh she
take your time is that blood buddy
she freaked out
i i it's okay
no it's not it's not okay
my mom tried to kill me so well that's
not
great so i stabbed her
i killed my mother i didn't expect to
start here
i never wanna hear you
say
[Music]
trying to do my most emotional
backstreet boys cover there that i could
possibly
manage for the start of this game jesus
okay
[Music]
they really do love this region huh
video games in general be all about this
region
pacific northwest i believe
fall vibes
this cute outfit i would wear all of
that actually it's a very cute outfit
you'll look good
this shoes yeah yeah i love the boot
just never need to wear
[Music]
nobody puts mascara on like that
no it's always i promise
oh thank you ron my birthday was
actually pretty good uh i didn't do very
much
but i uh i had people in my life who put
a lot of effort into making it special
for me even though i kept being like
oh my game's too loud
uh that might be better
so yeah they uh even though i kept being
like i don't care whatever
um people did uh put a lot of effort
into
making my quarantine birthday a good one
even though i didn't see anyone or go
anywhere
is that volume good that volume i did
get some fancy new sneakers
i did get some fancy new sneakers this
is a don't not game
miles low
uh yeah nikov i played virtually every
telltale game
bro i love fireweed
so one of you killed your mum was what
uh what i'm picking up here one of you
killed your mom
i think this looks like gameplay
okay first i'm gonna find the keys to
the old house
then i'm gonna drive to fireweed and i'm
not going to freak out no you're not
first
you're going to look at some stuff i've
got to make solid plans to see the
geminids
i wonder if tyler'd want to go is that a
made up bandwidth is that a real band
hey i'm trying to look at this not here
nope i didn't mean to do that not here
thank you master griffin massachusetts
i need to bring this to you i do love
the album
a spaceship
cool
i should probably get rid of this a
journey through the stars
but it makes me happy just to look at
that i mean in theory i have a bunch of
dvds that i could just stream
i don't throw them out
game is now too soft you say okay
make this a little bit bigger
there and you see how that goes maybe
that's a bit better i don't know
what is this daily knees
yeah no in my desk drawer maybe
oh i'm looking oh caught
for something i should probably check my
email one more time before i go
no i've already done that three times
this morning
time and i against any two the shape of
yesterday and summertime sweet
interesting uh yeah don't know
definitely do detail
the pants out of their environments ooh
can i see myself
hey girl how you doing
yeah uh oh
she's out of space any stars at this
time of day
i love that i too am into space
i don't know why it's like i only just
put that on put that together when we
looked at the telescope like it wasn't
already obvious but
all right this is too much stuff what's
in the drill
cute oh come on
why do i still have this wait every time
i look at it it reminds me of how very
simple people say
i don't know
allison and
booby
very good
okay cool well i'd like to leave now
where are we dropping boys
i still need to find the house keys well
you should know where you put your own
[ __ ] house keys
i don't feel like i understand why this
is my job all of a sudden
uh where else can i even look look here
she said in the draw but i feel like it
looked in the drawer um
under the bed you could drop your house
keys under the bed oh
right i stashed them down here
why why did you do that
video games ridiculous you're you're big
dummy yoda
so that's where you've been hiding that
must have been an expensive cameo
excellent i'm glad i said it correctly
tell me
all right i think i'm ready to go all
right let's go
to wherever it is that we're going this
space space
there is a donut game where you as a kid
kind of do go to space actually
ellie she's gonna be so awkward
dear tyler i know you're thinking a
letter
while weird and formal what's wrong with
mail
well i figured hey bro just wanted i'm
not reading this whole thing
oh it's from allison who's the other one
okay i can't believe i'm about to leave
this room for the last time
okay i'm pretty much done here but i
don't know what people do when they live
one and i'm like i really do love it
there i've been there i thought it was
goddamn beautiful like really genuinely
one of my favorite places on the planet
but uh
like what do you do in your spare time
john i am always streaming late the
reason i'm always streaming late is
because i
have a job i stream after i finish work
generally
i still do have more work to do tonight
though
breaking it up songs of innocence
shelter from the flood okay oh the
transgender
transgender man's guide to healthy
masculinity so i yeah i believe this
character is
a trans man hey little guy yoda you're
gonna be reunited with your sister soon
that's actually pretty cute do i have
any oh my sister and i have matching
tattoos so it's gonna be like do i have
anything that would make me think of my
sister
yeah we literally have matching tattoos
in the same place
cool i guess i'm totally ready to go now
bye but first i need to look at herbert
you're leaving this room and you're
gonna leave this [ __ ] plant here
you're a monster
what a dick
oh gonna miss these dum-dums
i don't believe that you have that many
friends in alaska i've been there
he's so handsome yeah he's pretty hot
yeah they're both pretty odd
it's true
this box of junk slash cheddar is now
yours but first laws of finders slash
keepers the this is
the i find these games always just like
try a little bit too hard to be cute for
me you know
oh yeah they're not they're not being
shy about him being trans at all
why is that the first thing that i can
read
how odd you couldn't let me read the
newspaper but i could read the calendar
um all right
hey aaron you know i'm bad at this but i
just wanted to say
you've been the best counselor an
at-risk yet redeemable youth
could want i need to make this cheesier
thanks for uh putting up with me and
helping me in more ways than you know
try to make it count outside of fireweed
survival is rebellion
thanks man did it make you all cringe
was it bad
you hate that
okay let's all go
you guys feel it
good uh can a trans man grow a beard
yeah absolutely i have
several trans friends albeit
of course
my dad actually uh i just got
presents from him today and he sent me
two plushies
they arrived for my birthday late it
happens shipping from australia takes a
long time wow
okay all right i'm going to be doing
that to my dad
jesus that's more brutal than whoever
stabbed their mom
great shot said sorry for the late
response but they did make another
combat orientated story oh yes i always
forget about vampire
um i didn't play it but i actually
watched max go the first time we see
each other in 10 years
hi tyler oh sorry i
it's fine allison okay somebody has a
good place to start you show your
siblings and you haven't seen each other
forever
it's good to see you
likewise haven't you seen each other in
10 years you
have anything else you need to get nope
this is it my last 10 years
in a bag i feel like this game doesn't
then we should get going look as good as
that we just have time to make the
morning fairy
i don't know i'm crazy like you look
good in that distance thanks
one of my mentees designed it that's
really good yeah
he's so incredibly talented i got a
couple of local coffee shops to hang his
arm
tyler ronan shaping the leaders of
tomorrow yep
we're screwed so
are you gonna miss anything about this
place also i just feel like
i would be very cold not having a beanie
or some kind of ear cup is in this type
of environment that's all i'm saying
very bold it'd be real chili i don't
know what you're going to miss man
i don't live here uh i'm going to see
the people just based on the fact that
there were the notes
in your house i don't know [ __ ]
honestly that's a good point miles life
took me a while to fit in but once i did
it felt like home they made me feel
safe that's true safe enough to
be me that's so great
i'm really happy for you all right
we planning to drive to delos crossing
or push
you are welcome to walk nah i'll take my
chances
need one last look or anything
looked let's go
the idea of even being in california
makes you sweat yeah it's pretty toasty
here
um my air conditioning did get fixed
though
which is obviously huge for me
[ __ ] i got 50g for that
game of the year game of the year
that was that easy
[Music]
no really i am 100 not creative enough
to make that stuff up
oh and just last week they had to turn
the ferry around because a bear was on
board
no way someone heard a commotion in the
back of a delivery truck so they opened
it up
and there was the bear fat and happy on
a literal
mountain of empty chip bags
you go where the food is oh i can relate
to that
so then wait are they on a boat right
now i'm not sure i think they couldn't
get him to leave so they drank him
probably oh poor buddy
shot in the ass just for getting the
munchies yeah well
you know what they say safety first and
i don't know how that makes yeah it's
different for everybody
common sense goes a long way in keeping
them from getting shot
the bear is fine tyler how long have i
been off the sticks now a while i mean i
did just
you hear they've been talking about
loosening up regulations
but that's what these games are meant to
be again i really don't like this style
game it's definitely not for higher bag
limits
um i've never really enjoyed them for
whatever reason
even bringing back hibernation i respect
what a lot of people do and they do
something different what kind of [ __ ]
gets off on killing a sleeping animal i
do love until dawn though i like it when
they're scary
i'm not against hunting but predators
play a vital role in the health of our
natural parks
where does this come from why are you
smiling i'm being serious
oh i can tell ranger tyler not yet
but at least i got yeah
all this damn i can't believe you've got
a bachelor's already
while i boast a half-completed
certificate in accounting from an online
college that may have stolen my credit
card number
you'll figure out what you want you have
time
again really liking the way she dresses
though i'm into it
like i'm about to drive straight into a
white out and my fog lights are dead
that seems bad that seems bad
i think that's bad i think that's a
negative we're going to take that as a
negative
you feel badly about what's happening
what about you
oh you guys should be able to see the
subtitles shouldn't you
trying to wrap my head around the fact
that you're right here how far
this is i don't know whenever how long
however long the stream's been
you don't have to apologize it's a lot
look why did we take the ferry instead
of the coast road
cause i didn't want to be stuck in the
car with you for an extra two hours we
have to take the ferry
it's the only way to reach delos from
fireweed i see
well good i don't think my stomach could
have taken two more hours of how you
handle curves
i'm sorry do you want to take over
driving when we dock
you're gonna have to get back behind
that wheel at some point you know
look i put a fireweed van nose first in
a ditch
hey at least you missed the porcupine
i'm guessing things haven't changed much
i'm trying to like even think of
something to say but i'm capital of
easter eggs
can't wait to get out of here yeah yeah
yeah sure okay
small town life guess that normal life
you wanted didn't live up to your
expectations i guess they're just trying
to introduce us to the characters it's
okay having cable and full-time
electricity was definitely a plus
but no one ever forgets anything in a
small town
you get marked a weirdo and that's it
that's your life
at least you had michael yeah do they
seem like they don't think they could
have survived high school without him
uh can anyone come in he doesn't have
anyone
watching he could but i haven't seen him
much outside of work lately
he's been busy with his dance and
helping his clan organize a potlatch
potlatch what is that
smoke coming out of stone house what's
the meaning of stone i guess someone
finally bought that old shack
that or the ghosts are cozying up by the
fire i think the new owners know it's
totally haunted i mean this is
tina did her best to keep them from
figuring it out i mean those mountains
until the paperwork was signed ugh that
house always gave me the creeps
those windows are like huge gawking eyes
do you think people will talk about
nobody talks about any houses this way
probably nobody's ever said that about a
house before right now
yeah richard i could see it being like
the start of oxenfree i love oxenfree
so we're really going back there huh
just stone house
and then we're going home yeah yeah we
are
think the house will sell no interested
buyers yet
turns out people don't line up to buy
murder houses with no electricity
now i'm interested at least it's got one
hell of a view
unlike juno hey juno has mountain views
of plenty
it just also has people and fun i'm
[ __ ] on stone house but that's
still thinking you might be where we're
thinking about it
hey can i ask you a question
oh i didn't realize that i was still
controlling him i didn't know this was
controlling
um i mean after you well
graduated i guess and became a mentor
three years ago
you still basically spent all your time
at fireweed
right pretty much there were a few times
i tried to go to these meetups for trans
people in juneau
but something always came up i probably
should have put myself out there more
but it was better to be around in case
the residents needed me
so you were free to come and go as you
pleased yeah
but why do you ask oh nothing just being
an overly invested sister some kind of
college seriously how you spent your
time
also i'm sorry the those camera angles
were probably infuriating for you guys
it was just
giving me something to do sorry about
that
[Music]
alison yeah
spit it out okay you need to promise not
to freak out
[Music]
did you motivate me please give me
something juicy
it's a gift from eddie
i know he's not your favorite person but
i'm sorry when you said eddie
i thought you meant chief brown as in
the police officer who arrested me
come on ty don't and your adopted father
the man who didn't let you visit me for
seven
years the fireweed administration backed
him up tyler
they thought it was giving me a lot of
personality drama here yeah well it
wasn't
it's a peace offering and you're the two
most important people in my life
version of uh i disappeared please
for me a mentor is
but they're a student as well or no it's
a gift tyler
you know what gift giving means in
clinkett culture good or just something
like playing
um it depends if you like
life is strange like it seems exactly
like like those are so i'm sure you'll
enjoy it if you like those uh not my
type of game like i don't think that i
would
finish this like it's just not the type
of game that i like i didn't press
anything
[ __ ] i know this is weird um but yeah i
imagine if you like those kinds of games
you'll feel
happy with this one i imagine he put up
with me at my absolute worst
and has always been consistent and kind
um let's just be an [ __ ] to make it
fun
exactly nice
yeah seriously yeah that was childish
what is wrong with you
yeah no need to be so dramatic
i'm the one who's being dramatic oh god
what a weird gift to give someone you've
been estranged from who you [ __ ] over
there why would you give them a ring
like what a weird thing to do
is it a bear
you're right they don't look like maxy
chloe did you hear that
doesn't sound like a bear but i can
still hope
in other words a jerk
i didn't need to dig in like that i'm
sorry no i don't want to apologize
why have we done this this is not a
narrative i agreed with
i'm sorry whales are cringe i just hoped
we could wrap everything up with a grand
gesture and move on to our perfectly
normal lives
what this isn't normal which one of you
murdered your mother that's all i want
to know still your brother
which one you killed something
still your sister
one of your mother and i gotta watch out
for you
would it ruin the moment if i said i
needed to call home
uh yes completely sorry
go ahead and stop apologizing all the
time
okay okay roy said a mentor is like a
support worker
but it's specifically in schools i feel
like i've never heard of this before
i don't know no no
hey it's me like i know of like guidance
counselors
on this boat not sure
boat stuff thank you slamming right
thank you yeah it was my birthday on
monday
i despite the circumstances and not
caring about it
um did have a pretty nice day
very chill didn't see anyone
this is a beautiful boat ride to be said
like i'd be losing my mind about how
pretty this is
so props to you for that
when everything else fails try doing
what the captain suggested
cute yo what up morning hello
enjoy the room real close to you
i love it i'm supposed to be i don't
think i could ever get tired of this
agreed where are you headed uh
delos crossing same here you from
seriously looking really close to each
other right
uh born and bred i think it's true
born and bred ah you don't say
i have moved anchorage around your age
yeah she's mostly alaskan natives then
clinky at hyder i haven't been home in
five years
okay um
sure ah my sister's planning to move to
juneau
good for her most folks i know never
tried living anywhere else
i'm alex by the way g'day alex alex good
morning thank you no relationship
huh dude george gershwin um
gershwin the pianist folks are always
there
is part of the community mental health
center initiative to have a mental but
it's usually a good thing
that makes sense i guess would you say
your name was i'd make them kiss if i
could
but they don't they won't get any closer
than this which is still very close
uh just call me tyler just call me tyler
all right good to meet you tyler
likewise sir all right
well what else am i supposed to do
hey allison can we take the scenic route
instead of the highway
isn't she on the phone allison we do i
don't think she can hear you
guess no this the boat man the captain
sounds very sinister
introduction to making a devil's club
tea
telling it dance performance under the
sea that's also a dance thing i went to
formal
something about apples expeditions
bed and breakfast what is this one a
canoe for sale
oh [ __ ] oh oh
strong and sturdy fiberglass
transform for something outboard
500 now [ __ ] that that's ridiculous
ridiculous for my neighbors
you trying to rob me absurd
okay where did allison go
hi we're almost there great because i
have nothing to do on this boat so
i guess i could like sit in the car or
something uh that'd be cool
oh the option was leaved oh this maybe
speeds it up
that's nice it's like the start of alan
week you know it starts on the boat
and then it turns into a horror again it
is just like the start valentine
yeah you go for diner and whatever and
then
and then suddenly you're killing people
with a flashlight and a pistol
and an axe
out of nowhere but it happens
any minute now
right yeah i'm excited about the
the control allen wink dlc despite
having beef with alan wake himself
i think he's a punk hates his wife
how am i supposed to like you and
support your goal if you hate your wife
all right yep
the lack of mcdonald's on this road trip
is inauthentic i would bet you money
these [ __ ]
ate mcdonald's you know road trip to
alaska and not have mcdonald's
uh i have no plans to stream the control
alan wake dlc no
rubbish is on a format you could be
right they finished the mcdonald's and
they laughed on the floor
thank you
[Music]
or starbucks that's a good call
that would be freezing cold where
are your gloves
[Music]
you people who live in the north of this
this continent are crazy
what are you doing wow it's basically
exactly like i remember it only
faded like a polaroid left on a window
who says that allison from the outside
it almost looks
charming sorry what okay
charm's not the problem structural
integrity
may be an issue the house you think
there's a chance
whoever buys it will just tear it down
yes
if someone buys it they can do whatever
they want with it
you wouldn't care at all would you say
weird like
it's crazy that there are some people
whose parents still live in everywhere i
look poem they grew up in i just see her
it just seems so nuts i can't even
imagine
alison not moving for that one i can't
imagine either
just start this tomorrow no
the only way to get this done is to do
it
okay so what are they doing like moving
out the like dead parents [ __ ] or
something is that what's happening
after you okay
let's go
that's also gonna be really cold locked
well it's a good thing i remember this
i don't know why he didn't expect it to
be sure that's the right key
oh why they wouldn't have broke to their
own home right maybe someone
changed the law right who would change
the lock on us
i don't know we're screwed you got a
plan b
yeah we find another way in every video
game doesn't even know a locked door
that could keep the crafty goblins out
yeah we had a million ways in and out of
this old house
at least one of them's gotta work
okay the crafty goblins huh
the crafty goblins i haven't thought
about them before clap on this and then
get in that window should i say
us no we almost spend more time as
goblins than we did as kids
oh do you remember all the other
characters the moon hack
the i remember how mad she'd get if we
didn't use the compost
and she always knew when we were lying
wait's not
gonna need a hand sorry i'm absolutely
just no i should be
all fine if we just get this board out
of the way i could probably squeeze
through
the splinters you need something to pry
it off
screwed in pretty good we need to stop
touching it
all right well that's probably going to
be in in the barn but i also just want
to look down here because it looks
really pretty
this is very pretty you know
you know what i'm saying like that's
scenic as hell can you imagine living
here and
just having this be your backyard
i do remember when i was in alaska
finding something really strange about
driving down a main road and just having
mountains on every single side
like i don't know why i didn't expect
that it is
crazy beautiful i saw a moose that was
very exciting
a couple of moose actually you really
want to go out there
no you're right i tried and it turned me
around oh that's interesting i guess i
don't want to go out there never
mind uh screwdriver is probably going to
be
in this bond situation
this is all very cute
oh looks like a neighbor came by it's
funny
i can't remember any signs of them when
we were back probably because our mother
scared the [ __ ] out of him
yeah she scared everybody else off too
is that why one of you killed her
i'm pretty sure
at least the shed's still standing yep i
don't want to think about what might be
living inside of them i do
well better alive than dead
let's deal with that later hey it's
locked all right
yeah okay there should be something in
here that'll work look a screwdriver hey
i see a screwdriver now all we need to
do is get inside
wait i am um
i'm feeling something strange
oh this is very remember me okay
memory flashbacks and don't leave this
room until everything looks as clean as
a whistle
ugh this is the millionth time i've
gotten in trouble because of you
you and your big mouth hey you were
thinking the same thing you just weren't
brave enough to tell her
what good would it do it's not like she
ever listens to us anyway well i'd
rather scream it right in her stupid
face than be a quiet little
i guess they had maybe like oh we forgot
the key
we need to put it back maybe we could
hide it somewhere
you know for fun goblins are supposed to
help the princess
not play mean tricks whatever my sister
and i were pretending to be like to make
her even worse
[Music]
it did but that was a memory of us 10
years ago right i
vaguely remember it happening i think so
and uh that's new right
yeah we could share thoughts and
feelings but
we never replayed memories like that
why would it happen i feel like you're
not right
i don't know quite the way you may be
pretty weary
like it's weird but our voice was always
a good thing i feel you should be
flipping out a bit more
if you both just collectively watched a
memory reika
so maybe that's just me exactly hunted
they seem
very calm about finding out that they
have near the barn
superhours me too right
let's focus our bond
anybody give me this give me okay i'm
gonna remember where this is
it's very pretty
hurry let's go see the silent frog
coming i'm coming
what stop sulking i told you already i'm
sorry
no you're not okay guess you don't want
to see what i put in the treasure
[Music]
okay i guess we know where to search now
we just have to remember which one
is the silent frog it gonna be this one
it's gonna be it can be someone which
one of you is hiding the key why
couldn't you just check all of them
damn where's the key seriously kidding
oh come on why did they make it sound
like it was dramatic okay okay
sorry nice job cuteness
i also feel like they could have opened
the window um
but it's fine it's fine
all right let's go lad let's go
hmm what's this some kind of bird
situation huh who left this box
where did you put it looks brand new
where did you just put it
guess it's your lucky day bird friends
got it all this for a screwdriver
you got a better idea how to get in all
right let's do it
screwdriver and i'll put the thing if
for some reason bird food
this house does look pretty [ __ ] up i
feel like i wouldn't be this willing to
to do this but it's fine do they not
have something they can call who has
access to the house it is their house
right i don't know
devastatingly not a backstreet boy
simulator
are you sure you want to go in there
this was our very first den remember
who knows what lives down there now i
also just feel like when my sister go to
places we went
and i we went to as a kid we don't go
this was our first whatever we just
don't reminisce this is okay down there
yeah i don't know everyone's different
tyler
oh that's not funny then why am i
laughing
okay fine but you're still an idiot
all right i'm going in for real this
time
cool okay i'll see you at the front door
in a few minutes
let's do it
it's such this game's like a very
interesting mix of being graphically
impressive and not being graphically
impressive
but yeah ouch
are you okay what happened my fault i
just hit my head like an idiot
wait what where are you
ty i'm outside
but i can hear you in my head okay cool
yeah i'm all superpowers
it's back oh [ __ ]
dragons straight ahead need to go left
you're right
nothing here of course i was
hey little guy you're a little cutie
what you doing
put that in your butt too tyler i would
have taken gold
not even in your dreams thank you
i would have taken gold not even in your
dreams
goblins figure great great love that for
us
oh cool truck
i remember i buried a bunch of yu-gi-oh
cards in this kind of space i don't know
why i did it
i just know that i did that at once no
point it was on the right
my bad maybe that was somebody was
trying to steal them from something
pass the treasure straight ahead you
know i almost convinced myself
our voice was just another trend in my
hideout
spooky why am i still afraid to say his
name it was marianne's creation
she made all the creepy characters
i already did that why am i still afraid
to say his name
he was mary ann's creation she's still
suckled in it she made all the creepy
characters
it is it is oh
it's right there got it okay yeah
hi beautiful
tell me why uh
dr frosty said i'm usually extremely
open-minded about games
and weirdness but this game seems kind
of bad so far i feel like if they
stopped talking it would get a lot
better
look again i do not like this um
not my kind of game i'm definitely not
going to finish this or play it after
the stream
uh but i don't think that makes it bad
uh i think it's doing kind of exactly
what it wants to and i think that a
certain audience will absolutely love
this
um there are certainly specific people
who will love the like
cheesy kind of campy nature of
two siblings hanging out speaking to
each other through their minds uh yeah
it's definitely not bad
uh just potentially not your personal
preference i certainly love weird but
this is like a different kind of
weird but i also didn't like life is
strange very much
tyler are you in there yes
it'd be real dusty in there i'd get
asthma like immediately i would have
gotten asphalt under the house
first to be fair coming like i'm on like
several layers of asphalt
are you okay sweet jacket i'll live good
to hear your voice again
yeah same here so
coming in or what i don't think this is
a family type game
just working up to it i think it's more
like a teenage girl type game
maybe
[Music]
which is cool well you're left we're
here
here we are
so how do we get started
we figure out what to keep what to trash
i appreciate the way they paced this
like i don't know
why they're trying to get their house
why they're doing this i appreciate that
but they didn't just tell me immediately
oh thank you 50g oh my gosh
wow yeah got our machines
what am i supposed to be doing all right
let's see broken shelf
broken jar and the washing machine
the dryer never worked to begin with
mary anne thought dryers were straight
up evil
energy is marianne hated hanging drippy
laundry
parents i refuse to marry ann's room
let's not go in there until we
absolutely yeah
i am curious we should take down the
creepy
masks if we don't want to scare the
buyers away oh so now you don't want to
scare someone with those masks
that's probably true um
are these authentic lincoln i doubt it
i'm surprised marianne would buy fakes
20 years huh this bathroom still smells
like stop talking about marianne so much
we were so competitive about who
measured taller like
we actually had anything to do with it
and after all that
it ended my sister and i were yeah
competitive none of that crazy
stretching i did made any difference
suck it sara
i tried to bury this dress in the
backyard but marianne caught me mary
anne
huh yeah well we both know pretty
was never my thing
what are we definitely very detailed
well i'm certainly not gonna wear it
donation pile it is then wow
wow i forgot all about her weird
concoctions
and how she was always testing them on
us like we were
laughing that's not good we don't like
that we don't like that
handmade soap still here after 10 years
i would like to say that about the to
make soap
i don't know why that's a thing that
i've been like i feel like that would be
fun
but i would like to try it
um nice kitchen cool is that bleach on
the count out or uh
what was she hoping to do with all these
jars she used to barter from bleach in
your morning coffee
jam she tried everything to make ends
best mom
you think we ever really believed that
or were we just trying to make her happy
either way it wasn't true
yeah calling your mom by their full name
again assuming
guess we never had time to complete the
collection these came out of one of the
prizes i can't believe i'm going to say
this
publicly but you'd slide the quarters
inside on the little tray i love him and
magic
out pops a sticker i think i love nut
i think nut
it's really cute
that's what i'm saying
after all this time i thought i'd feel
more prepared to deal with this mess
2005. of course did y'all fix the window
though
the last few months are almost all black
blank
only a few appointments most of them
canceled what kind of appointments
hairdressing i think oh yeah she did
that for a while
that's cute um
okay cool
did somebody have a party or something
as well why did my controller just
vibrate
why did that just happen
she pinched every penny
efficient gotta get your savings
somewhere
why does my controller keep vibrating
what are you trying to tell me
are you seeing something i'm not wow
i'm so embarrassed for this spaceship
minnie da vinci's we were not oh these
are cute she saved every drawing we ever
did it's super cute there's a couple of
these i might keep
she took so many pictures yeah
like she had to document every second of
our lives
a true instagram mom yeah let's roast
her she kind of had an
eye i guess but it was annoying uncle
eddie could never understand why i hated
getting my picture taken
yeah same for me all my photos at
fireweed i've got my hands over my face
a perfect about kingdoms of amla
reckoning revived sand
i yeah i [ __ ] love that game dude i
feel like i have so much to play right
now
but yeah i will get it i will i will
purchase that boy
why are you vibrating is it because
there's a memory in here oh it
is there we go
mom about me joining the hockey team
mom sorry what not now
maybe next year but you promised to keep
whining and my next year will become
never
look i'm in the game cut my hair your
hair is fine
but i want to cut it short really short
what stop moving tyler look i'm tired
and i'm busy let's talk about this later
you always say that
she seems quite nice actually marianne
said no to everything thank you
made me so pissed i like my jacket shoes
those last few months
thank you yeah and completely deaf to
everything i was
telling her i needed she pretty much
always said no to me too
true but it felt personal with me
that's a rude thing to say i didn't
realize how much i missed the smell of
firewood
i missed the cold winter nights curled
up here she was meaner to me
coco yeah marianne was so tired she was
usually asleep on the couch
ah that's why it was so nice no
mary okay i get it you don't like
marianne
we get it i'm saying so we didn't wake
her up
[Music]
women and children too
this is a dope house though
like pretty sick
yo what are you doing down there what do
you think i'm doing
trying to figure out if anything in
marianne's mess is worth keeping
any progress not really what about you
what are you doing up there uh
check out our room i'm tired of her mess
let's dig into ours
right i guess it's time to mainline
nostalgia all right cool
that's going to be up here i suppose
let's go seriously we didn't detail the
hell out of this
okay open the door this is bigger than
my apartment
know this i want that this feels
what do you do with all this space see
if this were my apartment i guess like
my bed would be here
and then i got like my coffee table here
and then my pc
is like here and then my bathroom's like
this is literally like the size you copy
if we don't move fast this whole thing
is going to melt do you copy
we're basically walking talkies on the
legs you know yeah
well how do you play ice road trucker
assassins without a walkie-talkie for
troopers
mr serious all of a sudden you have
piqued my interest
whenever we asked for a tv she'd just
bring home a big stacker what a boss i
think
it is a favorite respect the [ __ ] out of
marianne you may not agree when we start
digging into the hbo back catalog
we'll see
is it a yoshi on a stick
very nice
will i do a live stream of cyberpunk
2077 once it comes out
um probably i don't want to be [ __ ]
doing at that point in time it's months
away
i don't think that far ahead but
probably yes
good night joey not well
all right
a box i'm excited
look what i found what only our greatest
creation
the book of goblins seriously
it was in that chest all these stories i
had ideas for so many more
marianne wrote a lot of them yeah it's
one of the only times i remember her
being
my piece it's actually pretty cute
wow they really done wrote all this
very nice odd design
ah where is it you looking for something
in particular
my diary you never told me about it yeah
with the way marianne was i tried extra
hard to keep it a secret
marianne yeah that day she found out
about it
is he thinking this or is he what are we
stuck here
when we shouldn't be oh no okay
what's now hmm
mom where is it what did you do with it
what now
i can't find my diary i know you stole
it give it back
sweetie whatever i do it's just for your
benefit
you read it didn't you you had no right
to do that
i have the right to do whatever i need
to protect my little girl i'm not your
girl
i hate you you will always be my little
girl
and no matter how hard you fight me i'll
fight twice as hard okay so i think
what's happening here is that the plot
is that the mother is transphobic
that was the young tyler wanting to play
sports and being told no
hiding diary i think that's what what is
happening here
generally i just feel like this is
overwritten it's just like that they're
trying so hard to give so much
exposition
um but again i know that there are a lot
of people who really like this type of
game and uh
[Music]
they'll be angry at me when they find
this video i never saw it coming it
happens
it happens she told me right to my face
she was willing to hurt me to keep me
from transforming that's
pretty [ __ ] up wait so tyler's
probably the one that killed my mom
tyler there is no way you could have
known she'd go that far
oh
okay but do you need to get it like now
that diary was important to me allison
she has great eyebrows
writing down my thoughts helped me
realize who i am very good great
well let's go find it
[Music]
well i don't know where you put your
[ __ ] diary tyler jesus christ
you think her room is still locked it
always was
i'm not looking forward so much for my
dream of being at hockey did you start
playing hockey though mary ann thought
sports were too
aggressive too competitive and too group
thinking
these these conversations are so
inorganic but it's fine
again i felt that way about life is
strange as well and people love life is
strange so
oh memories are happening
ice king finally caught the head his
furious voice could be heard throughout
the forest
for your wickedness you will be
eternally bound to the lake
what no way quiet let me finish
you will no longer be allowed to leave
not even under a full moon
the moon was in prison too and she never
again
tried to escape
and then the title what do you think not
bad right
i guess that's okay but i would have
changed the end
what no way i always wonder if they have
actual child actors do that stuff
i totally forgot about him you're
comfortable with the ice king dude you
know what's your adventure time his name
he was too powerful so we trying to get
into this bitch's room
or what hold up what
remember this unfortunately
you must solve my riddle to earn the
right to enter the princess's sanctum
nothing a good hard shove won't take
care of i mean
yes we could brute force it but it might
be kind of fun to finally solve it
right we have different definitions of
the word phone
okay well if we break it we're just
gonna have to fix it for the sale
so let's at least try not to you have
the book of goblins
uh dr defrosty you're supposed to hand
it over that about
gone home i really like gone home that
is uh definitely what it is
supposed to make what are you looking
for the image on the door
it's making sure this is nice his hair
actually reminds me of lawrence
marianne road it's like the the lawrence
heka you have a way better memory than
me
well the book of goblins was my creation
and you'll never let anyone forget it
here it is the one about the princess's
party i wonder if this game is going to
do stuff while you like swap to this
fantasy world they keep referencing and
then swap back
give it a read i think the symbols may
represent something in the story
that seems likely which could be
interesting first ghost memories
out with one of the games before the
storm
what a weird day a kid what a weird
childhood touche
okay so i'm solving a possible
book of goldman's prof what did she say
it was was it this one do i have to read
the whole thing
uh once upon a time and hang on
once upon a time in the deep ancient
forest the crafty goblins spied on the
secret keeper as she made her rounds
and how did the door open
the secret keeper nodded blah blah
moose's eyes goblins
i have no idea am i reading the right
one i wasn't paying attention or is it
the big frog is punished am i reading
the right one
i'm unclear
it's the princess party that i need to
read okay
the princess party the princesses potty
uh is it just gonna be in that order
then
you're headed by a pelican the moose
the bear well that would mean pelican
moose bear
which would make this mousse this i
could be totally off on my guess here
though
uh how to okay uh so this one's gonna be
pelican
moose bear
eh eh probably wrong
are you sure you're going to be able to
crack i didn't feel confident about that
i just i just did the oldest thing i
just started give me some time i
probably should
all right but i'm here when you're ready
to admit defeat
okay bear invited her right on his back
the pelican the moose princess had a
very good time at a party such a good
time that she forgot to say thank you to
any of her friends noticing this the
fairies devised a bit of mischief
the princess went to open a gift she
found three identical boxes at the edge
of the glen puzzled she turned back and
got the entire party advantage because
you've taken your friends for granted
we've hidden them from you but we like
games uh
guess who has given you each of these
presents and you'll get your friends
back
inside was a torch
a sword a bag of coins
i may have been thoughtless but i
appreciate all my friends that have
given to me and all they've done she
gave back so fairies but one by one she
gave the animals a hug and thank them
for the presence of party and all they
had done to help since she moved into
force i have no idea
uh
i just don't i don't want to read it is
kind of my problem
you know but like i probably should read
the whole thing but i don't want it
so here we are is this game available
for purchase i think so
i think it's out now but i don't know
um all right if the gifts are a torch
a sword and a bag are they on here
no probably have to guess who gave her
the torch for the first one
who give who gives you torch
she said someone doesn't want her to get
lost in the room when it's dark and then
i always see right from wrong which of
my friends will give you a gift like
that so
who would give you a gift like that boy
is an attentive
the moose stolen far sided the bear
muskrat i have no [ __ ] idea
hmm
i feel like the bear would give her the
sword probably
money to buy food when i'm hungry and
clothes when i'm cold i think that's
what i'm trying to
[ __ ] line up here i'm pretty sure not
positive but pretty sure
but i think bear is sword which means
the second one is bare
um organized by the moose
so i'm gonna say the moose would give
her the money maybe
so who would help her when it's dark and
see right from wrong so
it's if it's bare and then it's moose
pelican
and the [ __ ] guest is only gonna
pelican i'm just gonna swap these two
where's the frog even [ __ ] play into
it
loose
oh no still no you think you're any
closer to my dancer i have no [ __ ]
idea
no clue i think i need some help okay
let's think this too okay i read the
story what was i supposed to get from
that
look at the wheels the symbols are the
same as the animals in the story
yeah and the princess had to guess who'd
given her the presents
yes i bet we have to do the same thing
that's what i figured i don't know these
people
i don't know i'm not friends with these
animals
jesus where's the frog uh the frog
doesn't have any details about him
the pelican is poisonous and attentive
the moose is stalwart and far sided
which means
like the moose i guess
could also be the one who would give her
the gift in the dark
right right maybe
i don't know they're not at the point
where they start giving up and tell me
what to do i asked for help
um so i think based on the moose being
farsighted the moose could maybe have
given her
the right from wrong one right so it
could be miss
i still think the middle is bad money
muskrat maybe i'd [ __ ] try it
i guess [ __ ] what did we decide most
was money
middle i still think it's bad i'm going
to try a [ __ ] muskrat
yeah you think you're any questions
i don't know i have no idea
i guess i need some help i think i need
some help
okay let's think this through i'm 21
and i still can't crack a puzzle made
for 11 year olds
we just need to think like me [ __ ]
marianne okay what is it is anyone else
in here
the pelican the pelican is poison
attentive
uh pelican it's a never emptying beak
just based on never ever maybe i'm
personally glad that doesn't come
naturally this could be a pelican maybe
never emptying money you oh okay
that was a wild nonsensical guess that
i don't feel like was rewarding because
it was [ __ ]
hmm that's cute and boom
we're in
i'm still not really sure how that
happened but it's fine it's funny
what's this game about about well jack
right now i think like two
um maybe like 20 somethings maybe i
don't know how old they are
i expected this to feel more you know
like a win i'm sure you can find a
description online of what the game is
about speak for yourself
that i can speak i'm the one who solved
the riddle well yeah well we guessed
why do i feel like you're not gonna let
me forget that the pelican one i don't
really feel like added up that much
it's fine again very neat book though i
love that
where do you think we should start
looking
uh we're looking for a diary i don't
know where in this mess would she stash
someone else's personal thoughts
looking for a diary i would put it
right here that's where i hide
all of my family members diaries
beautiful it's here
i knew it obviously i [ __ ] knew it do
you think she read it
of course she was nosy as hell
hmm
what you looking at bud
a voc you seek as a youth camp presented
by the alliance with traditional
families
and a book on raising a trans child okay
okay okay
tyler tyler
why is she so dramatic right look
is it because she tried
and that seems nice where did you find
that it was on her desk with her papers
seriously are you [ __ ] kidding me
look we gotta be really careful not to
overthink this
but it doesn't make any sense
sh she was mad right
she was mad i i cut my hair she attacked
me because i cut my hair
she was mad and she attacked you we both
saw it
then what is this [ __ ] that
she maybe tried sometimes i don't think
maybe that is tyler
come here
like i would think that someone could
like you can't do this attempt and also
[ __ ] up
when i finally made sense of a few
things
okay if the issue that he's having is
that she seemed like she was
consistently against it and then she
showed maybe a sign it'd be very
confusing
that was your first thing about someone
thinking the world made any kind of
sense
it was very confused her birthday about
10 years in the grave
and she's still finding new ways to piss
us off
yeah because it seemed like she was
always awful about it but maybe she
considered it once and yeah yeah i could
see that being complicated
i guess i'm going to be back i think i
need some air
okay
family is difficult it's true
it's good it's a good point
so we're like gonna sell the house now
and get rich or
hey what's up what's the plan
is that the end of episode one
i don't know are you really really sure
it could be because i think i'm not
supposed to do it i think i can stream
the other websites but i'm not supposed
to i don't know
okay
here we go
oh there is more to episode one okay
just wanted to make sure
i expected it would be about three hours
whoa
is it all gone which i haven't been
streaming for that one yeah
it looks amazing that is not how that
works cutting hair is
way more [ __ ] difficult than that let
me tell you
i can't wait to show mom she's been so
sad lately
more than sad she's been scary
yeah but not tonight though it was
almost like a party
thank you with all that hair i caught my
own hair and you're thinking [ __ ]
guess everywhere family you're my sister
i feel more like like your brother
sister we look out for each other
but i'm pretty sure i just gave you a
really bad haircut
that frankly looks tidy as [ __ ] all
things considered okay
cutting hair mom and hair gets
everywhere and it sticks to your socks
it's a real real problem sticks your
socks even after washing it
it's complicated
so they weren't twins oh i don't know
i think that i think they're twins
good luck sleeping in a bed full of hat
exactly dude exactly
oh [ __ ] a light outdoors
what could it mean
[Music]
why am i like
mom
oh no no no no
[Music]
this is wrong this is so wrong
are you drunk what's happening
what do you what are you doing with that
gun where are you going to shoot your
lips where you going to shoot your kid
what's uh what's the plan lady
it was much worse than you getting
railed
oh geez something wrong with me yeah she
might have been high as [ __ ] also legit
i always want to apologize for how much
i flip this is like this game is like so
little interaction right
that um sorry if it's annoying to watch
me spin in my chair swivel would be the
correct term
glad we found your diary but it's fun
for me
me too i guess she was trying to figure
out where you were at
yeah well she should have asked i wasn't
some goddamn research project i was her
child
yeah i'm going to say a hard no on
reading your kid's diary
that's going to be this is going to be
my
stance about the book
raising your transgender child do you
even
know how rare these books were in 2005
that's a good point was she trying to
figure out how to support me that is
what i would infer
maybe which she wasn't trying she never
it doesn't make sense i know you cutting
your hair was what set her off right
allison she read my diary she already
knew
it wasn't my hair and if we were wrong
about that
[ __ ] you think she read it
it's possible she never even opened the
diary and that things are exactly like
we always thought they were so they
think that
if she did and they aren't god tyler
sure i mean we could have been wrong
don't die good does it do to ask the
question now
you mean other than not having to live
with the thought that my mom tried to
kill me for being me
tyler that's pretty heavy you want there
to be something to find
something that'll make it all make sense
but she was unhinged so that's it then
she was crazy so he is the one who
stopped it nothing else to say
and i think they'd be better off if we
tried to move on tried to kill him and
talk to
the people who knew her see if that book
makes any sense to them people don't
want to talk about marianne
they pretend like that night never
happened got it
oh maybe tessa has answers
what about tessa she was marianne's
closest friend
let's ask her about it sure but i'll
warn you she's particularly touchy about
this subject
well maybe she'll talk to you yeah you'd
hope that she i was always your favorite
operative word was kids who's fine
we need to go by the store anyway god
damn mom to get a few things for the
repairs got stabbed or whatever
two seagulls one stale hunger bread i'm
not sure i like that analogy
listen i know you don't want to keep
talking about this but you're obviously
not going to be satisfied
it's very confusing i can't figure out
if that's being dramatic or calm because
it seems like it changes every sentence
why rush the house sale that's a great
question to ask immediately right now
so i was thinking
do we need to be in such a rush to sell
this place oh my
god tyler really what everything we
thought we knew about marianne just got
thrown out the window
maybe it did or maybe nothing's changed
and we dig up that nightmare for no
reason
so it's not worth the risk to you not if
it means throwing away all our plans
your plans it's your plan to sell the
house
your plan to go to juno me i'm just
looking for some goddamn peace of mind
how about you start digging without
putting off the sale
and if it seems like we need more time
we'll talk about it then
okay beautiful background though again
really oh is something wrong what could
possibly be wrong after this this
conversation
you've been on edge all day is there
something more going on with you
it's nothing pretty sure it's not
nothing but i'd like us to be on the
same page
i thought we were on the same page sell
this place as quick as possible
and move on that book changed everything
and then we found the book and things
changed you really don't get that
it's just with the way you avoided this
place for the last three years
i thought you wouldn't want to spend any
extra time here oh so that's what this
is about
maybe a little yeah it's just
you graduated three years ago i see
the first time personal drama
relationships
families i understand it's not that i
didn't want to see you
i just wasn't ready to be tyler
in delos crossing i tried to visit you
i tried to go to your fireweed
graduation i wanted to bake you a crappy
boxed cake and take
awkwardly post photos i know but you
shut me out
all i got was non-responses and
half-assed evasions
ooh spicy it was about me
not you and making it about you is
really not cool
tyler seriously that's it seriously
okay then thank you angry horsey
i'm pretty sure you played this map in
battlefield 4
uh we have a plan
so we have a plan yep we ask around
about marianne
but we also stick to our repair schedule
brilliant sounds good to me
ollie's diary it's been a long time
since i heard that name
was i the only one who ever called you
that actually no
i used it at fireweed for a while until
i settled on tyler
most people were pretty chill about the
switch not everyone though
what do you mean i had a mentee who
refused to call me tyler
he didn't want my help he didn't want
any [ __ ]
i'm sorry i like the name tyler
by the way thanks um
i just realized it has snh crossed out
and it says cool plan
and it says ap that's me i'm ap
oh my gosh uh i'm gonna stop it there
you guys
um i think this actually probably is
something that i imagine
is very cool for the trans community
um i didn't realize how much this game
was going to focus on that and that's
i feel like seems like a pretty massive
feat when
you know obviously very underrepresented
uh group of people in video games
or often represented as a joke so that's
pretty dope
still not my type of game uh
i've just never liked the the
interactive novel stuff i've never never
really enjoyed it
unless it's scary in which case i'm
always for it
but i think for the most part like it's
just not i didn't like life is strange i
don't like this kind of thing really at
all
i just don't find the the interpersonal
drama to be as interesting as like
combat gameplay um as much as i also
respect the hell out of their uh
art direction here and the detail like i
for sure
appreciate the craft that goes into what
specifically they try to do
just ain't for me just ain't for me
so that's it for me today everyone
obviously get your own read on whether
you like it or not based on this like
hour plus gameplay that i have uploaded
how long have you been streaming for an
hour and a half ish
also alaska's beautiful and if you
haven't been you totally should it's
[ __ ] gorgeous
huge fan um i will see you guys soon i
might
do wasteland tomorrow i do have a really
big day tomorrow though so we'll see if
i can
even bring the mustard i busted the
energy to stream after my giant work day
tomorrow
i will see you all next time
oh